[Music]
if you're a fan of one piece I bet
there's been so many times you've been
amazed by characters entrances whether
it be during their introduction or
simply at an important part of the
series it could be because of their
unique appearances crazy powers of
snazzy laughs or amusing verbal tics of
which there are plenty in this pirate
tale no doubt these moments make these
characters shine brighter stand taller
and stay with you longer there are some
characters that stand out more when they
make an appearance at a pivotal part of
the story characters who make you stand
up and take notice so today we bring you
a list of the top 10 badass entrances in
one piece without further ado let's get
this ship sailing
[Music]
we start the list off with an early
favorite a hockey powered Luffy rescues
King Neptune from the villainous holy
Jones in the Fishman Island arc with the
great white shark Fishman sword inches
away from Neptune's neck sheera Hoshi
house for the captain of the straw hats
to save her father
seconds later Luffy bursts out of a pet
shark's mouth landing a kick on the
human hating pirate holy sent flying and
crashes into the walls to the relief of
the watching townsfolk the public
executions averted Neptune and his
princes lived to fight another day and
the straw had to take the lead to
reunite the underwater Kingdom with the
world above the surface
we just know our favorite pirates are on
their way to conquering the new world at
number 9 we have the moment when a
low-key G rescued smoker in the New
World
the Luffy lure Alliance has made a mess
of doflamingo's plans by destroying his
artificial devil fruit manufacturing
Factory on Punk hazard and taking his
mad scientist sees a clown hostage
having the smile literally wiped off his
face the warlord flies into the toxic
island in a flurry of pink feathers
itching for a fight but Luffy and gang
are long gone leaving smoker and his g5
unit to face the music which brings us
to this next entry on our list clearly
no match for toffee the cigar-smoking
marine captain's on the verge of a very
stringy death when suddenly an icy front
blows him to everyone's surprise smoke
is saved by the timely arrival of a
low-key G who turns Davi into a giant
icicle the Pirates quick to recover but
knows better than to fight the former
Marine admiral as laid-back as he might
appear so I saw Warren or Tom or Dodson
Ando
[Music]
after the ice storm comes a bolt of
blinding yellow light number eight
Israeli savings or Oh cos aru has Zorro
at the receiving end of his killer beam
on Saab OD this is one of the first big
crises facing the straw hat pirates the
fallen swordsman needs a miracle to make
it out of this encounter with the flashy
Admiral alive luckily Silver's Rayleigh
flies in at lightning speed going
straight for kazar ooh and deflecting
his light beam with a touch of his
sandaled foot here we get a glimpse of
the power of the dark King a man who was
the pirate Kings first mate the straw
had to make their escape as Rayleigh
comes out of retirement to help them uh
sure in a brand new pirate era
[Music]
next up Luffy enters the battle to save
ace the captain of the straw hats has
done the impossible by breaking in and
out of the import down fortress from
there on making it through the gates of
justice and into the Marines island
headquarters of marineford
before the executioner's bring the
curtains down and his brother is easier
said than done it's nothing that
tumbling down from the sky on an
appended ship accompanied by an unruly
bunch of new allies and former enemies
convicts
hang on ace here comes hell as the
rubber man and his motley crew freefall
into marineford
it looks like a happy ending is in the
making alas it's not to be but that
discussions for another day and a
different list
[Music]
at number six we get our first eyeful of
the world's greatest swordsman Hawkeye's
Dracul mihawk at first there's a
flashback of piercing yellow eyes the
dark silhouette of a tall man in a cape
and hat and a fifty strong pirate fleet
lying asunder in his wake
next the man himself makes his
nonchalant entry sailing close to the
floating restaurant Bharati a on a small
boat no crew to his name with a swing of
his monstrous black sword he slashes the
pirate bully don krieg ship in half
snapping it into as if it were twig
first impressions don't get stronger
than this what follows is just as called
the legendary first meeting between
mihawk and the man who aims to wrest the
title of the greatest swordsman from him
roronoa zoro a wonderful tribute to this
moment is recreated some 500 episodes
later when a post time skips Zorro
emulates his mentor and cuts a ship in
half of the star Bodie Coast now how's
that for a parallel
onto the top five now and it's the slow
talking fast moving kazar once again the
Navy admiral makes probably one of the
most epic entrances in the entire series
as he takes off from his warship and
lands on Sabo deriding a cannonball
resplendent in his yellow striped suit
and yellow glasses all hell's broken
loose on the archipelago with Luffy
punching the living daylights out of a
celestial dragon and trafalgar law and
captain kidd joining in the malay but
kazar owes his usual core self not even
flinching from a bullet to his head he
may not be as ruthless as a canoe or icy
cool as Oki ji but don't let his
laid-back demeanor and lazy smile fool
you
the Admirals not to be taken lightly as
the straw hats find out the hard way at
number 4 we have Kaido another man who
loves to make an entrance
everytime he appears in the series in
the ongoing arc the straw hats have just
arrived in 102 fight the king of the
beasts and are making their presence
felt as they sumo wrestle and brawl
their way through samurai country
against all plans to lay low and take
the Jonker by surprise is that even
possible with luffy around as the sky
darkens an ominous cloud swirl a huge
dragon appears out of nowhere we've been
given a million references to kaido's
superhuman strength but with the Dragons
of rival we get our first look at his
devil fruit powers as impressive as
kaido's inhumanely huge human form is
his horned fire-breathing self makes the
pirate and even more enigmatic and
dangerous being it's not for nothing
that they call him the strongest
creature in the world
kinda
[Music]
who
at number three we have one of the many
legendary moments from marineford
it's when luffy faces the admirals Luffy
is finally close enough to rescue his
brother ace but finds a formidable war
blocking his path to the execution
platform standing before him are the
three top Admirals of the Navy heck I
know
okichi and kazar ooh so near yes so far
you're not ready for this stage yet okie
G tells him bluntly and we silently
agreed but Luffy wouldn't be Luffy if
you were scared that easily even when
facing much stronger opponents he
attacks the Admirals unleashing a
barrage of kicks in trying to trick his
way past them this moment gets stuck in
our head as perhaps the first real
challenge thrown down to the Navy in the
world government by the man who would be
the next Pirate King
karema she thought Voss tunnel
we're almost at number one before that
comes a suicidal jump from a sky island
that serves as our introduction to the
one piece universe biggest and baddest
supervillain so far Kaido king of the
beasts one of the Four Emperors of the
sea captured by the Navy eighteen times
these escaped execution and near certain
death
forty times guillotines can't cut him
Spears can't impale him he simply can't
be killed even by himself as he finds
out after his jump which leaves him with
just a headache
Kaido is also the man Luffy and law have
angered in their quest to defeat him
sounds like a suicide mission for the
rookies right we'll have to wait and
watch to find out if that is the case
indeed
sineva so more common in Okinawa
saku-dono keidel
[Music]
[Applause]
now for the top it's the mighty shanks
ending the battle of marineford the war
ended tragically in the deaths of ace
and white beard but with both the
Marines and the Pirates and willing to
relent the casualties continue to mount
Kobe's desperate plea to work I need to
end the senseless fighting and stop the
loss of innocent lives only earns him
the Admirals ire as a kind who turns his
fists of molten lava at Kobe shanks
appears out of nowhere and saves the
young murid have come to end the war he
announces calmly and the swords fall
silent
Fleet Admiral Sengoku agrees and that's
how the paramount war comes to an end
just like that with just a word from the
redhead Yonko the navy even agrees to
hand over the bodies of ace and white
beard to shank so he can bury them with
dignity and he buys jinbei and law time
to make they get away with the
distraught Luffy the closing moments of
the Battle of Marine foot are a true
testament to the silent power of the man
who inspired Luffy to become a pirate
all those years ago even the Marines
know better than to mess with red hair
[Music]
boy what a touching I do still and there
you have it the top 10 badass entrances
in one piece we hope you enjoyed it
leave a like if you did I definitely
appreciate it tell us what you think of
our selection and if you think we missed
anything don't forget to comment on your
favorite entries from the series and
I'll see you next time on beanie tube
[Music]